We can define a pattern--let's say pattern is lit('a').
Now what is a pattern? Well, it's a function.
It's no longer a tuple.
We can apply that pattern to a string and we get back the set of the remainders.
It says, yes, we were able to successfully parse off "a" off of a string,
and the remainder is a string.
We can define another pattern. Let's say pattern 2 equals plus(pat).
Pattern 2 is also a function, and we can call pattern 2 of let's say the string of five a's followed by a b.
Now we get back this set that says we can break off any number of a's
because we're asking for a and the plus of that and the closure of a.
These are the possible remainders if we break off all of the a's or all but one
or all but three, and so on.
Essentially we're doing the same computation that in the previous incarnation
with an interpreter we would have done with matchset(pat2, 'aaaab').
Now we don't have to do that. Now we're calling the pattern directly.
So we don't have matchset, which has to look at the pattern and figure out,
yes, the top-level pattern is a plus and the embedded pattern is a lit.
Instead the pattern is now a composition of functions,
and each function does directly what it wants to do.
It doesn't have to look up what it should do.
In interpreter we have a way of writing patterns that describes the language
that the patterns below to.
In a compiler there are two sets of descriptions to deal with.
There's a description for what the patterns look like,
and then there's a description for what the compiled code looks like.
Now, in our case--the compiler we just built--the compile code consists of Python functions.
They're good target representations because they're so flexible.
You can combine them in lots of different ways.
You can call each other and so on.
That's the best unit that we have in Python for building up compiled code.
There are other possibilities.
Compilers for languages like C generate code that's the actual machine instructions
for the computer that you're running on,
but that's a pretty complicated process to describe a compiler
that can go all the way down to machine instructions.
It's much easier to target Python functions.
Now there's an intermediate level where we target a virtual machine,
which has its own set of instructions, which are portable across different computers.
Java uses that, and in fact Python also uses the virtual machine approach,
although it's a little bit more complicated to deal with.
But it is a possibility, and we won't cover it in this class, but I want you to be aware of the possibility.
Here is what the so-called byte code from the Python virtual machine looks like.
I've loaded the module dis for disassemble and dis.dis takes a function as input
and tells me what all the instructions are in that function.
Here's a function that takes the square root of x-squared plus y-squared.
This is how Python executes that.
I loads the square root function.
It loads the x and the 2, and then does a binary power,
loads the y and the 2, does a binary power,
adds the first two things off the top of the stack,
and then calls the function, which is the square root function with that value, and then returns it.
This is a possible target language, but much more complicated to deal with this type of code
than to deal with composition of functions.